abente is a former Somali minister of
planning and international cooperation
and joins us now from nairab good to
have you with us sir on Al jazer I mean
the arrangement does come with
diplomatic concerns too that being that
Somalia will not be happy and in the
last hour or so the Somali cabinet has
said Ethiopia's action uh an offensive
that endangers the stability and peace
of the region would you agree with
that there is no question this is a
dramatic development with profound
consequences for regional instability in
the Horn of Africa and keep in mind Horn
of Africa is already one of the most
fragile regions around the world so I
think Ethiopia's provocative action is
certainly going to create so much
problems in the region already I mean
ethiop Ethiopia has been trying to find
a route to the Sea for some time I mean
negotiating that path has not been easy
why has it been easier to deal with
somal land rather than with Somalia
well from a Somali perspective there are
a number of Dimensions to consider here
one is Ethiopia probably uh judged uh
probably incorrectly that Somalia is too
weak of a state to resist uh what is
effectively a a coercion not even a
negotiation really and secondly um this
is by far the most egregious violation
of the sovereignty of Somalia by a
foreign country in in about a decade and
a half and the last country that
violated somalia's sovereign was
actually Ethiopia when it invaded back
in 2006 which ended disastrously as we
all remember and thirdly the last
invasion of Ethiopia of 2006 in fact uh
uh led to the rise of al-shabab the most
violent U militant group in the region
and so you can only imagine what this
one would do um in Somalia and across
the region I mean that also seems to be
this element though uh despite sort of
the geopolitical sort of uh worries that
you know you scratch my my back I'll
scratch yours and there is benefit to
both sides in this particular agreement
if if we're to believe what's written on
paper I mean Ethiopia gets access to the
water Somali land gets a stake in the
Ethiopian National
Airline it seems like they're quids in
basically aren't
they well I mean that's what they said
on paper but keep in mind that ethopia
um is now a lot more weaker and divided
internally than it was 15 years ago when
it invaded um half of Somalia number one
secondly Ethiopia is also having another
geopolitical Dynamic with Egypt Al on
the Renaissance Dam and thirdly Ethiopia
is now trying to dismember Somalia a
member state of the African Union and
the charter of the African Union in fact
to protect the sovereignty and
territorial Integrity of all member
states the fact that the the African
Union's seat and headquarters are based
in Adis Ababa and that Ethiopia is is in
fact capable of doing something like
that really flies in the face of of a
global cooperation or cooperation
between Somalia and Ethiopia for that
matter well I'm sure there will be
issues certainly for the African Union
to consider because obviously such
recognition or such um uh recognition
would would break the charter but the
the the other issue here is uh
geopolitical politics because the port
itself in theory would be administered
by the United Arab Emirates and Arab
nations are having an influence across
the Horn of Africa the UAE obviously
also uh backing one of the sides in
Sudan it's also had influence in Libya
how much of a concern is that or is it
something we should be considering when
we when we when we're talking about
these relationships uh between Ethiopia
and its
neighbors I mean there's no question
that there are other G political
dynamics that are at play and they will
crystallize in the next few weeks and
months and certainly Ethiopia's now um
announcement was even though it was
dramatic it was not entirely unexpected
in fact the prime minister of Ethiopia
was was vocalizing his country's desire
to gain access to the Red Sea uh but
they could have achieved that very
objective through diplomatic means
through trade um arrangements with
Somalia and other countries I mean
Somalia obviously is blessed with the
longest Coast in Africa and certainly I
think the Somali leadership was prepared
to engage um in a meaningful discussion
around this issue but this move now
really um uh you know takes the whole
discussion into a new level and of
course if other countries outside of
this region get invol evolved I think
you can only imagine that you will see a
conflagration across the region very
soon for the moment we will leave it
there it's been good to get your insight
into this sir thanks for your
time thank you for having me